die ministerpräsidentin von mecklenburg
vorpommern ist uns zugeschaltet manuela
schwesig befürchten sie eigentlich dass
auch bei ihnen an gericht dieses
beherbergungs verbot kippen können und
dann müssen sie fürchten dass tausende
berliner doch an die küste kommt ich
befürchte gar nicht dass 1000 berliner
an die küste kommen denn wir freuen uns
über alle gäste aber wir haben seit mai
juni standards das eben wenn es reisen
aus risikogebieten sind dass das dann
test gibt damit haben wir auch gute
erfahrungen gemacht dass der eine oder
andere der ohne test kam und dann
getestet wurde und positiv war eben
nicht oder sozusagen erstmal kantine
konnte und wir haben ja schon von anfang
an immer strengere regeln beim reisen
gehabt auch am anfang für tagestouristen
da ist immer hier und da was beklagt
worden und unser ovg hat bisher bei
jeder klage zu der frage reise
beschränkung von außen bestätigt dass
wir als hoch tourismusland mit millionen
von touristen gute gründe haben zu sagen
wir müssen den reiseverkehr und da sag
ich mal kontrolle haben wir haben sofern
sie trotzdem sehr optimistisch was
unsere regeln angeht ihre hanna
vorsichtiger dass wir in den
risikogebieten regeln aufstellen genau
dazu werden wir gleich noch kommen sie
sagen in die quarantäne sollen die
menschen bis der zweite test da ist die
reisen werden de facto studiert
millionen menschen können sich jetzt
nicht auf den weg machen sagen sie
schade für die berliner aber was können
wir dafür also lieber sollen die
berliner ausgesperrt werden als dass sie
sie nicht einreisen lassen
es geht nicht um aussperren es geht um
sicheren tourismus und wir hatten seit
der korona pandemie 5 millionen
touristen im land und das wird ja oft
gesagt ja seht ihr das geht ja aber es
geht halt deshalb weil wir diese regeln
schon von anfang an
also wir haben da nichts in den letzten
wochen hektisch eingeführt sondern es
gibt es bei uns seid sehr lang und wir
haben damit gute erfahrungen wir haben
jetzt aber auch die situation dass wir
in einem zum beispiel touristischen
regionen wie die mecklenburgische
seenplatte kurz vor der orangene farbe
stehen und natürlich müssen wir gucken
wie kriegen wir das im griff ich halte
es nicht für richtig dass man zum
beispiel sagt so eine ganze stadt wie
berlin ist betroffen sondern ich würde
mir schon wünschen dass wir das
konzentrieren zum beispiel auf bochum
risikogebiete es gibt ja virologen und
wissenschaftler die sagen es sollte in
den risikogebieten selbst festgelegt
werden ich habe mich von anfang an darf
um eine bundeseinheitliche regelung
bemüht auch gestern mit daniel günther
zusammen aber wenn andere keine regeln
treffen dann müssen wir mit schutz auf
bürger aber auch mit schutz auf
touristen regeln treffen ich will noch
mal sagen dass wir durchaus oder
urlauber haben die anreisen wir testen
diese urlauber auch im zweiten test
machen unsere leute vor ort viel arbeit
nachdem aber gestern das ampelsystem für
die risikogebiete eingeführt wurde und
wir sicherheit haben dass jetzt auch in
den risikogebieten gehandelt wird haben
wir heute mit unserem tourismusbereich
besprochen dass sie gerne noch mal
schauen können ob unsere regel
pragmatischer werden kann ob wir
vielleicht auf quarantäne und zweiten
test verzichten können sagt aber das
reisen aus risikogebiete gibt ohne dass
es irgendeine zusätzliche maßnahme gibt
das kann nicht sein
bodo ramelow ist bei uns der macht die
ministerpräsidentin schon eine kleine
einlassung ministerpräsident von
thüringen herr ramelow jetzt haben sie
sich gestern vertagt und zwar oft den
acht november da sind die ferien vorbei
hier soll sich der grundentscheidung
gestand das spiel sicherlich legen
nein das hat mich veräppeln gar nichts
zu tun es hat etwas damit zu tun dass
wir mitten in den herbstferien sind und
uns gemeinsam auf das vereinbaren wollen
was manuela schwesig gerade gesagt hat
ich finde den vorschlag den kollegen
schließlich gerade gemacht hat sehr
begrüßenswert und würde ihn sehr
unterstützen dass wir die amtsärzte und
die gesundheitsämter in den abgebenden
stationen also da wo der hotspot ist
in die lage versetzen dass sie das mit
in die bewertung nehmen und die
maßnahmen dort getroffen werden und ich
habe immer gesagt ich halte mich an die
regeln die uns ein amtsarzt aus der
region übermittelt wo die dinge
passieren und alle anderen müssen sich
darauf verlassen können dass das bei mir
genau so passiert
das ist das was manuela schwesig gestern
abend vertreten hat und ich finde wir
haben jetzt die nächsten tage zeit
gestern abend haben wir diesen einen
teil nicht geregelt aber das ampelsystem
das was ich gerade gesagt hat haben wir
gestern geregelt und da haben wir große
schritte nach vorne getan und was mich
stört ist dass wir über die muster
quarantäne verordnung nicht reden dass
wir über das bundesweite test system
nicht reden das gestern mit beschlossen
worden ist machen wir gleich
sie haben in thüringen auch noch
niedrige infektionszahlen herr ramelow
sie können relativ jetzt natürlich genau
so klein wie ein schrei acht wochen
hatten wir nur 47 infizierte und heute
haben wir 500 überschritten also eine
verzehnfachung in acht wochen das macht
mich auch nervös also es ist nicht so
dass ich anfangs sage die kollegin
schwesig sei jetzt diejenige die was
blockiert oder der kollege daniel
günther hätte kein problem mit dem was
er da vorträgt sondern so haben wir
gestern noch nicht diskutiert keine
mediale wahrnehmung die ich heute von
unserer konferenz höre ist eine ganz
andere wie die sitzung an der ich
teilgenommen habe ich habe an einer
teilgenommen in der 16
verantwortungsvolle menschen miteinander
acht stunden intensiv gearbeitet haben
um die weichen zu stellen damit wir
wirklich die infektion bekämpfen und
nicht irgendeine geschichte machen ihnen
dürften berliner nachreisen
zu uns kann im moment jeder aus der
bundesrepublik deutschland kommen der
nicht von seinem arzt verboten kriegt
seine stadt oder sein gebäude zu
verlassen so und die bundesrepublik
deutschland ist der rechtsrahmen in dem
wir uns bewegen oder das
infektionsschutzgesetz gilt für ganz
deutschland nicht für teile und nicht
nur für ein viertel wir müssen uns
darauf verlassen dass dieselben regeln
in jeder region gleich angewandt
vielleicht angewandt werden und damit
sind wir bei jonas schmidt-chanasit
virologe bernhard nocht institut hamburg
wie logisch ist in ihren ohren herr
schmidt chanasit dass die menschen nach
sizilien fliegen können und nach kreta
aber nicht nach schwerin und nicht
nachrücken
naja das ist eben verschiedene ebenen
was man hier natürlich betrachtet ist
man die eine richtung weil sie die leute
reisen aber nicht nur in die eine
richtung sondern sich reisen natürlich
auch aus diesen gebieten nach berlin und
trägt man hier ein bier und das wird
natürlich nicht berücksichtigt die
entwicklung ist sehr dynamisch
ministerpräsident ramelow hat das gesagt
und man kommt einfach mit dieser
regelung die man da im kopf hat gar
nicht hinterher hinter dieser
dynamischen entwicklung insofern ist es
wichtig dass die amtsärzte vor ort die
genau wissen so zu sagen wo die probleme
sind die die quarantäne sozusagen
verhängen dass die das genau auch
durchsetzen können und dazu befähigt
werden und ich glaube das sind die
springenden punkt immer wir haben
probleme nicht neu regeln erfinden zu
müssen und so schaffen wir müssen die
regeln die gut sind die müssen
durchgesetzt werden das ist das
entscheidende
damit sind wir bei susanne jona sie ist
vorsitzende des marburger bundes also
aller krankenhausärzte frau jona auch
ansehen die frage die sich nun mit
diesen beherbergungs verbot noch mal
befasst im sommer appellierte der
bundesgesundheitsminister und irgendwie
eigentlich die gesamte regierung man
sollte doch eigentlich besser urlaub in
deutschland machen
wer sich daran gehalten hat ist jetzt
der dumme das problematisch daran ist
dass wir jetzt menschen testen die keine
symptome haben sondern die einfach nur
ihren urlaub antreten wollen
und das ist deswegen problematisch weil
wir diese test kapazitäten nicht mehr
für die menschen haben die symptome
haben oder die getestet werden müssen
als kontaktperson und es macht überhaupt
keinen sinn wenn wir jetzt laufzeiten
von test untersuchungen haben das heißt
ein patient oder jemand dem wir getestet
haben erst nach drei tagen das ergebnis
hat das ist unser hauptkritikpunkt
zusagen durch diese regelung
verschwenden wir tests die wir woanders
brauchen und deswegen halten wir das
beherbergungs verbot für falsch er sagt
auch bodo ramelow ja und wir fragen noch
mal schmidt-chanasit auch sie nicken
nach den pendlern und den
geschäftsreisenden weil die sind ja eben
explizit ausgenommen das heißt hier in
berlin am brandenburger tor wird berg
sind sie genau nicht auch ich die nicht
ausgenommen kommen wir auch noch dazu
das heißt aber in berlin brandenburg
gibt es einen unglaublichen verkehr der
ja genauso dynamisch für kontakte so
genau es geht letztendlich nicht um die
reise an sich es geht ja um das
verhalten der
vor ort und da muss man sozusagen ran da
ist doch jedem klar dass man eben nicht
eine feier mit 600 leuten jetzt abhalten
kann und das sind genau die punkte denke
ich wo man eben auch als eingegriffen
hat und jetzt geht es darum dass
konsequenter umzusetzen
das heißt also die zahl der kontakte ist
entscheidend und eigentlich dann doch
nicht der ort weil ich kann ja auch in
einer ferienwohnung auf kreta sein da
habe ich wenig kontakt wenn ich jetzt so
ein richtiger oder sie können auch oder
konnten vielleicht auch mit 600 menschen
im kreis fährt eine hochzeit feiern ist
wahrscheinlich nicht so häufig wie in
berlin oder köln aber theoretisch wäre
es möglich gewesen so und damit begrüßen
wir rené gottschalk er ist der leiter
des gesundheitsamtes in frankfurt einen
schönen guten abend nach frankfurt herr
gottschalk sie sind parallel dazu auch
noch für die whu beratend tätig und auch
für das lka aber erst mal eine ganz
praktische frage wenn sie heute hier bei
uns im studio wären müssten sie dann
morgen in frankfurt in quarantäne gehen
auch wenn frankfurt selbst risikogebiete
nein ich bin ja kritische infrastruktur
und damit dürfte ich auf jeden fall
weiterarbeiten aber mit mundschutz okay
ihr amt in frankfurt ist auch zuständig
für den frankfurter flughafen da sind
wir bei einem nächsten paradoxon die
reisen nach europa oder besser gesagt
die grenzen nach europa sind nicht
geschlossen aber innerhalb von
deutschland führen wir jetzt quasi
grenzen ein
macht das sinn naja also manchmal fühlt
man sich so ein bisschen die zeit des
dreißigjährigen krieges zurück versetzt
was was wichtig ist die ich bin ja so
ein abend wie es eben auch schon
angesprochen wurde der alles das machen
müssen regeln muss die amtsärzte dürfen
auch tatsächlich die grundrechte der
menschen außer kraft setzen aber dabei
haben wir das ermessen ganz oben
anzusetzen
und wenn ich mir klar mache dass also
hotels zb oder beherbergungsbetriebe
keinen hotspot in der letzten zeit waren
dann ist für mich das also ich hätte es
zumindest als amtsarzt nicht erlassen so
ein beherbergungs verbot
können sie denn noch mal sagen ob reisen
tatsächlich ein treiber der pandemie
sind also wir hören ja heute aus dem
bundeskanzleramt auf jeden fall solle
man reisen vermeiden erst recht wenn man
eben aus diesen risikogebieten bekommen
sind reisen denn per se ein treiber
dieser infektion
na sie waren es also gerade im august
und september haben wir in frankfurt
sehr sehr viele reiserückkehrer gesehen
die positiv waren
und das sind insbesondere menschen es
waren viele deutsche menschen die in
mallorca oder in kroatien genauso weiter
gefeiert haben wie letztes und
vorletztes jahr was wir momentan halt
machen ist diagnostik vor prävention wir
testen
sehr viele menschen die zurückkommen
aber wenn sich diese menschen das hat
kollege schmidt an das sind ja schon
gesagt wenn die sich so verhalten würden
das eine infektionsgefährdet nicht
gegeben wäre dann wäre das problem auch
viel geringer wir fragen noch mal frau
schwesig
angela merkel war unzufrieden mit den
ergebnissen des gestrigen tages
wenigstens an diesem punkt und hat
irgendwie auch dringt egoismus da
kritisiert das was hier in der runde
jetzt gesagt wurde wir verschwenden
diese wertvollen test kapazitäten ist
das in ihren augen an grund- und ein
argument
frau merkel war dass er unzufrieden weil
nicht das gelungen ist was sowohl bodo
ramelow als ich eben gesagt haben weil
wir waren wie gesagt daniel günther und
ich hatten den vorschlag gemacht ob es
nicht möglich ist dass wir zu einer
regel kommen dass man ihn in
risikogebieten entscheidung trifft
ob reisen weil es noch angemessen sind
oder nicht denn und und wir haben
ausdrücklich gesagt da meinen wir nicht
die risikogebiete pauschal ab 50 sondern
man könnte er noch mal mit
wissenschaftlern überlegen ob man es
definieren kann in hochrisiko gebiete
und wir hatten ja einen wissenschaftler
vor ort und auf meine frage wie er die
reisen einschätzt hat er eindeutig
gesagt dass die mobilität bei corona
virus ein problem ist
und dass man eigentlich bei
risikogebieten zur beschränkung von ein-
und ausreisen kommen muss nun würde ich
das selber auch für sehr
unverhältnismäßig finden wenn man
pauschal alles gleich wenn 50 ist dort
zur beschränkung kommt aber dass man
sagt bei hochrisiko gebeten wo wir
zurzeit die vermutung haben dass wir
dort gar nicht mehr hinterherkommen
schauen sie sich heute den stadtteil
berlin neukölln an mit 170 inzidenz
deswegen muss man ja nicht gleich ganz
berlin lahmlegen aber dass man hinguckt
kann man gezielt an hoch risikogebieten
ansetzen
das wäre eine lösung ich hoffe dass
einige darüber nachdenken
und leider ist es dazu gestern nicht
gekommen und was ja gestern beschlossen
worden ist ist dass man eigentlich sagt
ein risikogebiet ab 50 da schränke ich
die kontakte ein
zum beispiel in berlin oder in
risikogebiete nrw geht ja immer nicht
nur in berlin
aber die gleichen leute können reisen
nach schleswig holstein nach mecklenburg
vorpommern und da können sie sich
eigentlich treffen wie sie wollen und
ich will hier noch einmal eindrücklich
sagen dass es mehrere wissenschaftler
gibt die sagen ja die reisen rein und
raus ins risikogebiet nicht
unproblematisch es stößt stoßen sich
viele an den vielen tests die wir
verbrauchen das verstehe ich sogar
deswegen wäre eine regelung angedockt an
die hochrisiko gebiete besser dann sind
da schon zwei interessante einlassungen
wenn ich das so sagen darf nicht mehr
risikogebiet sondern hoch risikogebiet
und lieber im hochrisiko mitentscheiden
und es nicht ihnen in mecklenburg
vorpommern überlassen wer aus einem
solchen hochrisiko gebiet einreisen darf
nun gibt es natürlich einfacher schöner
da wohl auch eine sache ja auch noch
eine sache dazu ist immer schwer wenn
man so am bildschirm ist es wird ja
immer so getan als ob wir behaupten dass
hotels hotspots sind das sind sie
natürlich nicht die haben super
vorschriften und es geht nicht um die
übernachtung im hotel aber urlauber die
bleiben ja nicht im hotel sondern die
wollen sich natürlich auch überall
bewegen oder bleiben nicht nur im
ferienhaus sie wollen genauso einkaufen
gehen genauso die öffentliche
infrastruktur nutzen und es macht einen
riesenunterschied ich mach mal an
den vergleich mit bodo ramelow ist sind
über zwei millionen einwohnern thüringen
sie haben aber nur die hälfte der
touristen wie wir
wir haben doppelt so viele touristen und
es macht einen unterschied ob jetzt 150
tausend leute aus einem risikogebiet
kommen ohne dass wir auch nur von einem
wissen hatte sich infiziert oder nicht
ich vergesse wer recht wenn es regionen
sind wo wir heute wissen dass man nicht
mehr weiß wer nicht wer so zu sagen wo
die infektionsquelle ist und für
mecklenburg vorpommern will ich ganz
klar sein
wir kommen jetzt in einem landkreis auf
orange und da hat keine große hochzeit
stattgefunden da haben die leute sich
normal bewegt und wir haben schon
infektionen wo wir zurzeit nicht wissen
wo sie herkommen und zusagen in diese
touristische region schicke ich jetzt
noch ausgerechnet leute aus anderen
hochrisiko gebieten ohne dass ich weiß
wer hat eine infektion und wenn ich das
würde ich schon für fahrlässig halten
sie sich einen gefährlich sorgen dass
wir das einfach alles so laufen lassen
und in drei vier wochen über ganz andere
sachen reden das ist die berühmte
diffuse infektion darüber werden wir
noch sprechen es gibt de facto ein
urlaubs verbot für sehr viele menschen
das frustriert natürlich und es macht
den menschen die gastgeber sind das
leben nicht nur schwer sondern ruiniert
sie gegebenenfalls ich begrüße jetzt
caroline von kretschmann sie ist
geschäftsführerin eines hotels in
heidelberg einen guten abend frank
rutschmann zu ihnen
jetzt hat ausgerechnet heute ein gericht
das verwaltungsgericht in baden
württemberg das beherbergungs verbot
eben von baden württemberg gekippt das
heißt eigentlich könnten sie jetzt
wieder gäste empfangen oder firmennamen
vollen namen die runde
ja wir können wieder gäste empfangen und
darüber sind wir auch sehr froh der
verwaltungsgerichtshof in mannheim hat
also mit sofortiger wirkung des
bewerbers verbot was ja sehr umstritten
war als unverhältnismässig gekippt und
das heißt ab heute mittag als es über
den liveticker kam neben bier oder
würden wir auch wieder buchungen
annehmen wenn sie denn kämen wir müssen
sagen wir haben endlich gestern schon
damit gerechnet dass ist
beherbergungsgewerbe und nicht
weitergemacht wird aber es ist nicht
entschieden worden obwohl ärztevertreter
virologen rechtswissenschaftler eben
sowohl die sinnhaftigkeit als auch die
fordern ist es verboten in frage
gestellt haben ich hätte mir gestern
schon gewünscht dass die politik diese
massive kritik die im vorfeld ja
stattgefunden hat und auch dieses
regelungs chaos sie glauben nicht wie
viele gäste uns angerufen haben
verzweifelt weinend nichts wissen und
unsere kollegen damit umgehen mussten
es wurde ja quasi auf uns
operationalisieren dass es gestern schon
getroffen wurde und es wurde nicht
getroffen
deswegen habe ich jetzt die gerichte
gemacht wir sind darüber erleichtert
weil das ist ein kleiner leicht
leuchtstift am horizont kommt denn diese
beschluss für sie noch rechtzeitig genug
frau von kretschmann oder wie groß ist
bisher schon der schaden für ihr habt
mir also rechtzeitig kommt es in dem
sinne nicht weil der schaden ist schon
entstanden buchungen die wir vorher
nicht hatten die können wir jetzt auch
nicht nachholen und es ist auch so dass
die stornierung weiter anhalten und das
liegt zum einen an der immer noch großen
verunsicherungen es sind jetzt im moment
vier länder die es gekippt haben dürfen
wir reisen dürfen wir nicht weisen
vielleicht wird es wieder gekippt und
zusätzlich noch die aussagen gestern von
kanzlerin merkel und auch von
kanzleramtsminister braun bitte reist
nicht in deutschland bleibt zu hause
das bleibt natürlich hängen bei den
gästen und deswegen kommt auch nichts
neues rein
wäre es nicht noch schlimmer wenn ihr
haus jetzt ein hotspot würde also es
wäre natürlich schlimm aber mit der
gefahr leben wir seit ende des lockouts
und wir haben in der hotellerie
unheimlich viel gemacht wir haben
sowieso in der hotellerie schon immer
ein unheimlich hohen standard was
hygiene sauberkeit anbetrifft und durch
die bank weg haben alle betriebe
wirklich generalstabsmäßig hygiene
konzepte aufgestellt für alle
abteilungen bei uns im haus jede
einzelne abteilung hat einzelne hygiene
und sicherheitskonzepte
wir haben massiv noch mal investiert
plexiglasscheiben am front office
sowieso überall desinfektions spender
ist ja sowieso standard aber auch zum
beispiel jetzt für den herbst wenn wir
wieder aus der sommersaison von der
terrasse in die restaurants reingehen
wir haben die restaurants auf die
doppelte kapazität erweitert um die
abstände einzuhalten und wir werden
jetzt luft reinigungs filter mit uv c
nicht einführen
da brauchen wir für unser restaurant
allein vier die kosten zwischen drei und
5000 euro das heißt wir investieren
massiv in die sicherheit unserer gäste
und auch natürlich unsere kollegen und
abgesehen davon verändern wir sämtliche
prozesse im hotel seitdem locker und wir
haben kein befehl frühstück mehr machen
aller card wir haben ganz viel verändert
und unsere gäste spiegeln uns das auch
die sagen auch wir fühlen uns bei ihnen
total sicher sicherer als draußen
sicherer als bei uns zu hause weil wir
halten uns explizit an diese maßnahmen
wirtschaftsminister altmaier hat nun
gerade für ihre branche neue hilfen
versprochen wurde dass ihr haus denn
retten
das ist eine gute frage
die hilfen die versprochen worden sind
müssen natürlich erst mal ankommen also
die überbrückungshilfe beispielsweise da
ist ja 25 milliarden schwer
ich habe gehört da sind 1,1 milliarden
erst mal abgerufen
auch wir als unternehmen wir haben 122
meter zimmer mit 155 mitarbeitern
wir sind ein relativ großer betrieb für
die kleinteilige struktur und wir
bräuchten natürlich mehr als nur 50.000
euro pro monat was in der
überbrückungshilfe im moment gerade
angeboten wird weil wir natürlich einen
riesenberg an kosten haben wir haben pro
monat 750.000 kosten euro kosten das
schaffen wir natürlich gar nicht und
dazu kommt noch dass wir im moment noch
nicht an die überbrückungshilfe
rangekommen sind wir haben vom bund im
moment nur bekommen kredite die wir
verzinsen müssen und zurückzahlen müssen
und insgesamt stehen viele betriebe
wirklich am anschlag diese entstehen dem
rücken zur wand ein drittel der betriebe
ist kurz vor der insolvenz
und wenn diese betriebe wirklich
scheitern und allein in meinem umfeld
habe ich 15 hotel betriebsgesellschaften
sie in den letzten zwei wochen insolvenz
angemeldet haben
dahinter hängen ja ganz viele
mitarbeiter ganz viele familien und auch
ein gesellschaftliches und kulturelles
leben was dann verschwindet und wir
werden von den
maßnahmen jetzt zum beispiel
beherbergungs verbot ist für uns ein
schleichender locker und der 1 wir
kriegen einfach keine buchungen mehr
rein die leute haben angst die leute
sind verwirrt und da hätte ich mir
einfach gewünscht dass man mehr augenmaß
hat wirklich überlegt ist es eine
sinnvolle maßnahme hilft die um die
infektion einzudämmen weil wir sind
wirklich sichere plätze in den hotels
wir machen alles und das ist nicht
nachvollziehbar caroline von kretschmann
wir geben dass ihr in die runde weiter
vielen dank für dieses interview und
alles gute für sie und ihre kollegen
natürlich bodo ramelow jetzt hat gestern
wolfgang kubicki gesagt am 13
entschuldigung
diese maßnahme das beherbergungs verbot
ist evident rechtswidrig gerichte
bestätigen dass jetzt offensichtlich wie
groß sind die schäden die man da
anrichtet auch mit diesem hin und her
wenn gerichtet ist jetzt kippen
ich habe mich von anfang an anders
positioniert und ich habe es immer
wieder thematisiert ich habe auch
deutlich darauf hingewiesen dass wir das
containment zu organisieren müssen dass
wir die infektion bekämpfen und damit an
die quellen der infektion gehen und da
will ich einfach mal sagen wir haben uns
angeguckt was wir bei uns an
infektionsgeschehen hatten
ich habe zum beispiel feststellen müssen
sieben dialyse praxen waren infektiös
siebenmal in dialysepraxis wo es
eigentlich hätte gar nicht passieren
dürfen
also man einfach denkt das kann doch
nicht sein in fünfzehn mal in
krankenhäusern haben wir die situation
gehabt ich habe jetzt wieder aktuellen
lage meldung einen einen krankenhaus gab
da ist ein patient drei tage lang
behandelt worden ohne dass erkannt
worden ist das ja nicht nur infektiöse
sondern dass er ansteckend ist
hinter hat man festgestellt dass keiner
sich geschützt hat der ihn begleitet hat
das hätte nicht also irgendwie in hotels
deswegen habe ich ja immer gesagt ich
teile es nicht ich verstehe was manuela
schwesig sagt weil sie aus ihrer region
ein hoch urlaubsland ist und deswegen
sage ich reisen ist ein problem ich habe
zwei fälle gab einmal eine
junggesellenabschied die sind nach
budapest gefahren haben das kann man bei
sie gesagt haben nämlich so gefeiert als
wenn es wie immer wäre so und habe ich
gesagt also die ganze hochzeit bei
anschließend infektiös
und musste unter quarantäne und ich habe
eine seniorenreise gab ein kompletter
bus nach franzensbad und als sie
wiederkam habe ich gesagt die haben
corona tupper party gefeiert weil sie
auch im bus sich nicht beschützt haben
die alten leutchen ich kann den dass sie
gar nicht krumm nehmen die haben gehofft
endlich kommen sie raus er ander
franzensbad und jetzt sehen wir dass
tschechien schon wieder hoch
risikogebiet ist also einfach so zu tun
als wenn reisen gar kein problem wäre
wäre genauso gefährlich
trotzdem habe ich mich gewehrt gegen das
beherbergungs verbot und ich finde die
debatte ums bearbeitungs verbot hätten
wir gestern beenden können wenn wir auf
die fragestellung von manuela schwesig
eingegangen während der arbeit gefunden
hätten ja wählen wir sagen der amtsarzt
und das war eben der einwurf ja aus
frankfurt der amtsarzt muss in der lage
sein diese entscheidung treffen zu
dürfen und wir als behörden müssen dafür
sorgen dass sie auch durchgesetzt werden
das heißt ordnungsämter müssen fit
gemacht werden polizei muss eingesetzt
werden bundespolizei muss eingesetzt
werden und in den gesundheitsämtern
müssen wir dafür sorgen dass genügend
personal zur nachverfolgung / genau wir
sind herr schmidt chanasit noch mal ganz
kurz bei der situation der hotels da
haben menschen viel mühe viel zeit viel
geld investiert in hygiene konzepte in
schulungen und dann wird es im grunde
kaputt gemacht und die hotels stehen vor
dem ruin
was macht es irgendwie auch mit der
moral also ist es notwendig und was
heißt es irgendwie auch für das
zusammenstehen
also ich finde das problematisch gerade
wenn man eben das große engagement
aussieht diese ganzen bereiche sehr
sicher zu machen betrifft ja auch die
restaurants das sind eben menschen den
letzten monaten dafür gesorgt haben dass
keine infektion entstehen und wenn man
dann quasi solche maßnahme lässt auch
durchaus sperrstunde für einige sehr
sehr hart die sich an die regeln
gehalten haben dann ist das
problematisch führt eben dann auch eben
zu einer spaltung und letztendlich auch
zu einer nichtbefolgung von regeln
sofern glaube ich ist es immer wichtig
diese beiden seiten zu sehen auf der
einen seite die einfache maßnahmen
konsequent durchzusetzen auf der anderen
seite aber konzepte zu entwickeln zum
beispiel wie es auch in erfurt gemacht
wurde das entsprechende veranstaltungen
stattfinden können mit guten hygiene
konzept mit testungen das ist ganz
wichtig dass man ein ventil schafft
und nicht nur auf der einen seite mit
den verboten arbeitet ja herr gottschalk
auch die bayern die monatelang die
korona charts angeführt haben die weisen
jetzt mit dem finger auf berlin und
frankfurt nutzen manche
ministerpräsidenten die pandemie einfach
auch um die weiß ich auch nicht
selbstbehauptungs kämpfe auszuführen
auszutragen nein also auf dieses auf
diesen politischen boden will ich mich
gar nicht begeben
es ist so dass sicherlich alle regionen
im nach derzeit auch entsprechende
fallzahlen namen werden wir sind in
frankfurt natürlich ein bisschen
benachteiligt weil die den flughafen
haben wir haben großen busbahnhof mit
verbindung eigentlich nach ganz europa
so dass bei uns allein dadurch schon
eine große fallzahl auftritt aber es ist
es überhaupt nicht zu bestreiten dass
wird überall fälle geben und ich habe
mit offenen ohren gehört dass die
gesundheitsämter gut ausgestattet werden
sollen
mit personal allerdings man muss sich
mal vorstellen was das bedeutet wenn wir
also jetzt noch bei den ganzen fall
zahlen die wir haben und dafür ist diese
sieben tage incidents gut geeignet
wollen wir dann ablesen kann wie die
gesundheitsämter nehmen nicht belastet
sind
dann wird das dazu dass man eine unmenge
an personal braucht das es nicht gibt
selbst filme die stellen hätten das
personal gibt es nicht wie in frankfurt
haben hilfe jetzt von studenten von der
bundeswehr von anderen bereichen aus der
stadt und kommen mit dem normalen
containment wie dieser fachausdruck
heißt eigentlich schon gar nicht mehr
hin also da müssen neue strategie
entwickelt werden und das trifft nicht
nur hessen
das trifft alle bundesländer im lauf der
zeit und dann ist das jetzt das nächste
wichtige thema dieser sendung schaffen
wir es eigentlich noch die kontakte
nachzuverfolgen schaffen es die
gesundheitsämter noch und wir kommen zu
den beschlüssen des gestrigen abends
worauf man sich wirklich verständigt hat
nämlich ab 35 infizierten auf 100000
einwohner soll es dann schon neue regeln
sprich verbote geben
und das betrifft
auch automatisch wesentlich mehr
menschen künftig haben wir gleich zwei
schwellenwerte bei 35 neuinfektionen pro
100.000 einwohner gilt erweiterte masten
pflicht auch draußen auf beliebten
öffentlichen plätzen im öffentlichen
raum dürfen nicht mehr als 25 personen
zusammenkommen zu hause maximal 15
weitere einschränkungen treten bei 50
neuinfizierten ein so eine sperrstunde
ab 23 uhr kontakt beschränkungen werden
verschärft auf nur zehn personen in der
öffentlichkeit im privaten bereich
dürfen diese zehn aus maximal zwei
haushalten kommen sollten diese
massnahmen binnen zehn tagen den anstieg
der neuinfektionen nicht stoppen
treten weitere beschränkungen ein herr
schmidt chanasit helge braun
bundeskanzleramtes minister hat gestern
gesagt die menschen also wir sollten
vorsichtiger sein als die politiker
beschlossen haben das heißt die
maßnahmen reichen eigentlich nicht auf
doch sie reichen auch sie müssen aber
eben vom großteil der bevölkerung auch
umgesetzt werden und das ampel system
ist erstmal ein schritt in die richtige
richtung man muss aber natürlich
hinterfragen das kann er gottschalk
glaube ich auch sehr gut beurteilen wie
diese zahlen zustande kommen wir da kann
es deutliche unterschiede geben ob eben
dieser grenzwert zb durch einen sehr
begrenzten ausbruch hervorgerufen wird
dann muss man sicherlich nicht zu hart
reagieren oder ob ich eben ganz ganz
viele kleine infektionsherde habe die
schwer zu kontrollieren sind
design ist dass sie sich verbreitet dann
ist das eine ganz andere situation aber
sie haben den gleichen wert insofern
glaube ich kann man auch an diesem
ampelsystem durchaus noch arbeiten das
verbessern auch die dynamik da
reinbringen wie sich sozusagen diese
zahlen entwickeln aber es ist schon mal
ein schritt in die richtige richtung
richtung herr gottschalk sperrstunden
sind festgelegt worden alkoholverbote
kontakt beschränkungen sind diese
maßnahmen in ihren augen den
verhältnismäßig und vor allen dingen
nützlich also in der phase in der jetzt
zb frankfurt ist absolut damit kann man
natürlich die ausbreitung verhindern und
man kann auch wieder dazu kommen dass
die fallzahlen untergehen das hat
zb in münchen gut gesehen es muss klar
sein dass wenn der alkoholkonsum steigt
das dann eben auch die regeln die
vorgegeben sind nicht mehr so gut
eingehalten werden und deswegen ist eine
sperrstunde ab 23 uhr sicher ein
sinnvolles und probates mittel um das
wieder in die richtige richtung lenken
zu können ich glaube schon dass das geht
so und dann sind wir wieder bei der
frage herr ramelow reisen kann man
natürlich schneller verbieten als die
kontaktfreude der menschen wenn wir also
jetzt nicht mehr in die restaurants und
nicht mehr in die clubs und nicht mehr
in die bars sollen dann wird zu hause
gefeiert und sehr kontrolliert
wir haben jetzt gar nicht darüber
geredet dass sie nicht mehr ins
restaurant sollen
wir wollen schon dass sie ins restaurant
gehen wir wollen auch dass sie ins hotel
gehen also wenn sie es klar wissen
wollen also wenn dort die hygiene
konzept bei alle gut funktionieren dann
sollen sie auch ausgenutzt werden wir
haben das jetzt ausprobiert sogar mit
einem herbstmarkt mit 100.000 besuchern
die verteilt auf drei wochen mit einem
kontinent tatsächlich durchgelaufen sind
ohne eine infektion weil kein zelt da
war weil kein alkohol ausgeschenkt
worden ist weil ein ampel system
eingebaut war und weil eine
nachverfolgung technisch mit eingebaut
war
es hat alles funktioniert jetzt kommt
der punkt und das ist die frage
das ist die frage auf die wir uns
gestern aber alle 16 verständigt haben
dass die ordnungsämter ebenso verstärkt
werden müssen dass herr seehofer
angeboten hat dass die bundespolizei mit
eingesetzt wird das ist bei mir jetzt
auch schon praktizieren
der linke-politiker und sagt er mit der
bundespolizei mit der bundeswehr helft
uns
ohne die bundeswehr hätten wir an
manchen hotspots es gar nicht geschafft
also ich muss das mal in aller
deutlichkeit sagen ich bin der
bundeswehr sehr dankbar dass wir in
sonneberg eine stabs ärztin gekriegt
haben und zwei weniger die sofort bereit
waren
und wenn ich mir angucke dass wir in
apolda als die senioren aus franzensbad
zurückgekommen sind
das hätten wir ohne die bundeswehr am
ende nicht in griff gekriegt und ich bin
sehr dankbar dass uns der bund angeboten
hat diese hilfe wir müssen jetzt nur
dafür sorgen wir selber wie
in jedem bundesland bayern hat zum
beispiel seine mitarbeiter aus dem
statistischen landesamt umgesetzt in die
nachverfolgung das lasse ich jetzt
gerade prüfen ob wir auch weitere
bereiche haben die sie ersetzen nicht
den amtsarzt weil der amtsarzt muss das
jeweilige kommando haben aber sie
ersetzen diejenigen die routine arbeit
machen und das heißt es muss gut in der
routine gut durchorganisiert sein damit
die fragen der nachverfolgung auch von
einem studenten abgearbeitete arbeite
brennen können okay wir sind bei frau
schwesig und der frage frau schließlich
sollen jetzt wenn zu hause dann gefeiert
werden sollen irgendwie die nachbarn
sich bei der polizei melden wenn nebenan
irgendwie zu feucht fröhlich gefeiert
wird wie kontrolliert man dass das
bundesweite ampelsystem ist deshalb
wichtig weil die menschen sich
einerseits in deutschland einheitliche
regeln wünschen aber auf der anderen
seite hat ja die akzeptanz von regeln
auch was mit einer infektion zeit zu tun
wir haben eben landkreise und kreisfreie
städte da haben wir ganz geringe
infektionszahlen warum sollen wir den
menschen sagen du darfst jetzt deine
hochzeit nicht mehr machen mit 50 leuten
bin ich aber in einem risikogebiet da
muss sich die kontakte massiv
einschränken wir müssen uns vorstellen
dass wenn wir über 50 sind große
schwierigkeiten haben dann in den
folgetagen noch alles nachvollziehen zu
können und das ampel system schafft
jetzt einheitliche regeln was passiert
wenn welche infektionsquelle erreicht
ist und es ist gut dass wir nicht erst
auf 50 warten denn der weg von 1 bis 35
ist viel viel länger als von 35 bis
jugendlich das ist doch jetzt die
letzten tage passiert ruckzuck haben wir
risikogebiete und was herr schmidt sagt
dass man berücksichtigen muss
ob es ein diffuser ausbruch ist also
viele infektionsherde oder ich kann es
lokalisieren es ist das pflegeheim die
firma das ist dabei natürlich
berücksichtigt das ist beschlusslage
da brauchen wir auch an der stelle nicht
nachbessern weil wir das natürlich von
unseren experten schon berücksichtigt
haben ich sage ganz klar es ist ein
irrglaube zu denken dass wenn die
politik solche vorschriften
macht dass wir alles kontrollieren
können ich möchte nicht 1,6 millionen
menschen in mecklenburg vorpommern
kontrollieren und schon gar nicht mit
wie viel sie zu hause sind mit was wir
aber gute erfahrungen gemacht haben ist
dass wir von anfang an denken sie an den
shutdown
wenn wir gesagt haben dass und das
halten wir für wichtig dass dann viele
mitgezogen haben und deshalb sind solche
klaren regeln wichtig und ich kann heute
abend nur sagen wir sind wirklich auf
das mitmachen der bürgerinnen und bürger
angewiesen und wir sind in einer zweiten
welle
es gibt kein bundesland was nicht
steigende neuinfektionen hat und wir
müssen zusammen sehen dass es nicht aus
dem ruder läuft so und dann sind wir bei
frau jona und nochmal dem zitat von
helge braun der gesagt hat die bürger
müssen jetzt viel vorsichtiger sein als
die politiker beschlossen haben sagen
sie das was der gestern beschlossen
wurde hilft tatsächlich und sind die
richtigen maßnahmen ist dass ausreichend
damit ihre kollegen in den
krankenhäusern nie wieder überstunden
schieben müssen
na ja also das werden sie glaube ich
nicht leere lösen die regeln dass wir
nie wieder überstunden schieben müssen
schön wäre es ja aber das ist ja auch
nicht ziel der übung gewesen wie ich
finde wir reden hier jetzt sehr viel
über verbote und regeln sowie
kontrollieren wird dass das
entscheidende ist immer noch die
vereinigung die verantwortung jedes
einzelnen und das ist glaube ich auch
ganz wichtig klarzumachen
wir können noch so tolle regeln machen
wenn die menschen sich nicht daran
halten hilft uns das wenig und weil sie
das stichwort bundespolizei gesagt haben
die bundespolizei habe ich zufällig
gelesen hat veröffentlicht sie hat im
september drei wochen lang in zügen und
öffentlichen bahnhöfen kontrolliert
49.000 menschen ermahnt weil sie ihren
mundschutz gar nicht oder nicht richtig
getragen haben an so eine infektion an
einem bahnhof wenn sich da jemand
angesteckt hat wird das wird man nie
wieder nachverfolgen können von diesen
49.000 haben trotz hinweis der
bundespolizei über 600 waren sie
trotzdem nicht bereit die maske zu
tragen
da können wir noch so regeln erlassen
wir sind so gut durch die erste welle
gekommen weil die bevölkerung die
maßnahmen so toll eingehalten hat sich
enorm
solidarisch verhalten hat viele
solidarischer als das aus manchen
anderen ländern berichtet wurde und
diese regeln sind nach wie vor die
richtig wichtigsten und die heutigen wir
müssen uns im herbst jetzt nur ergänzen
mit dem elften und die korona auch
nutzen aber